Lakey say Oh is about sixty miles east
of Milan and in that Lake there's a
small island home to about 2,000 people
it's a population that's totally
dependent on boats and ferries Christo
who's wrapped the Reichstag building in
Berlin who's outlined whole islands with
bright pink cloth got an idea the
project is now another seven months to
go
they were walk in the world they walk
across the water yeah they literally
walk in the world on a path of yellow
fabric on top of 200,000 plastic cubes
this is the first project Krista will do
without his wife jean-claude she passed
away in 2009 unlike their past projects
the floating piers will be in place for
a limited time
this project will never be repeated
Christo and his team will disassemble it
after about two weeks when the project
is happening this very precious time for
a few days there the people know that
they're at the site of something because
every human is unique in the world and
they like to witness something unique
what's also unique is how these
multi-million dollar projects are
financed early on Christo and
jeanne-claude decided they needed to do
things differently out of necessity
he says collectors and dealers are
notoriously slow payers we cannot say to
our workers on Friday we cannot pay them
because mr. Smith who bought is not
paying
in 1982 Christo and John Claude formed
cvj corporation headquartered in
Delaware
it sells christos original works of art
from the 1950s to the present drawings
collages fabric there's a subsidiary for
each project right now Christo is
working on three of them including the
floating piers
Cuttino selling the fabric was very
complex Christo also buys back his
artwork if he sees it on the market and
thinks it's undervalued we're now the
biggest owners of works of art we have
these projects often take years it took
24 years for Christo and John Claude to
get permission from New York City to do
the gates from then Mayor Michael
Bloomberg has it gotten easier as you've
become better known as your project have
become been known to get past the
regulatory hurdles are more willing to
help your art world all know those
believe it's called difficulties never
you know I'm not was accused I will live
to have an easy way Christo keeps busy
when we spoke he was days away from a
trip to Abu Dhabi to work on another of
the three projects he's juggling right
now Christo is 80 and as our interview
ended we asked him if he has even more
projects planned you know general was a
saying we're so young a very easily
excited and if we have a new idea we
tell you right away and if I have a new
idea probably we learn by the way David
Gura Bloomberg New York